[Musique]
c'est la fin idéale
jacques en fin de journal pour les
nouvelles j'espère qu'elles seront
sensationnel braillard grande porte à la
base imam sur qu'outil des petits
commérages eu de très grands traits le
petit écho de la forêt il y à toutes les
informations à chaque nouvelle édition
on n'a jamais de déception ça vous le
découvrirez dans le tue des cours de
l'offre
au figuré vous cher téléphone que fifi
l'informer a été malade mais oui mais
oui le journal en parle
il paraît qu'elle se sent bien
aujourd'hui mais elle a été au plus mal
elle peut encore être en train
d'astiquer être fera t elle avait c'est
une maniaque du ménage
elle est peut-être balade est la balle
et un pont dans caustique par mégarde
max tu te croit drôle aux vrais main
c'est d'un goût bon je suis sûr et
certain que fifi est malade
louis inverse et zouk la pauvre fourmis
avait attrapé un gros j'ai la tête
l'autre comme une boîte de siens mon
corps comme un balai et le mouchoir et
râper comme une serpillière de ma maison
et d'une salle des ventes
il faut que je nettoie tous deux font
tant qu'homme et leveaux fifi n'était
vraiment pas raisonnable quand on est
malade on doit rester au lit le ménage
tout attendre non levé d'ald attend pas
on doit faire sans bandage tous les
jours on subit on ne doit pas se laisser
aller
syfy avait des principes ebit ne s'y fie
fille est malade ou rentrent dans son
lit tout seul nous devons faire quelque
chose pour elle il faut bien pas des
trains sur qu'elle n'est pas bien
excellente idée
zip vu récemment avec ma demande et oui
pour une urgence donc avons pas vu
fichiers depuis huit jours par français
son ménage
ça n'est pas certain elle est peut-être
très mal or il faudrait aller voir chez
discrètement très bien alors pas je suis
le lièvre qu'il vous faut visiblement ce
vigneron regarde pas la fenêtre de fées
pays du scrutin nettement du bvb bien
reviendra hors des facs gerut fait vite
fait des bonds dans ce tour fifille
avait entrepris d'astiquer ses cuivres
avec énergie sert méprise mais je ne
pouvais pas laisser becuywe dans cet
état il ne me reste plus qu'à nettoyer
mon gars tu m'enrichis info est la
mairie doute ma chambre
ensuite je n'aurai plus qu'elle avait le
pari de la cuisine ici y ait encore une
[ __ ] me ferait mal ici les choses
allèrent ballet très bientôt fini elle
est en pleine forme je rêve et faire mon
rapport dédié ici prg parti votera terre
chez mademoiselle de la cigogne
mission accomplie et baby alors alors
elle fait fort ménage à fond comme tous
les ans mais elle porte un sale pour ne
pas prendre froid voilà elle porte le
sol mais c'est très inquiétant elle a
peut-être attraper un torticolis il vous
croyez c'est évident mais elle fait son
ménage et où transpirent et c'est
excellent pour les torticolis
s'il y avait un torticolis je me
coucherai moi aussi moi aussi moi aussi
je l avoue très tôt n'est vraiment
malade aux vingt couches une fille fait
son ménage donc n est pas malade
si vous la ville a stick et ses cuivres
et 10 et 15 8 ème étoile à son garde
manger affront à faire puisqu'elle la
vraie série dans ses rideaux et
puisqu'elle la vraie le pavé de
sacrifices accusent ils elle parlait
aussi de faire sa lessive d'or dessinés
par elle
nous sommes inquiétés pour rien tout le
monde était rassuré mais la pauvre fille
était loin de se sentir en forme wii 6
épuisé générer plus je vois bien que je
vais bébé trop lui si le cinéma très bas
le rejoint et bachir téléphone si notre
ami fils y était resté au lit ses amis
seraient venus l'a soignée peut être
comprendre at-elle enfin que faire le
ménage n'est pas le seul but de sa vie
n'est ce pas un bientôt chez un petit
téléphone pour une nouvelle édition du
petit etc ou de le ferai
[Rires]
[Musique]